well did did you and your wife like wait
till you were married or no yes my wife
beautifully was a virgin your wife was a
virgin
that's so cute
how old was she she was um 35. she was
35 year old oh my
she grew up in the christian home so
that really helped as well yeah that was
one of the things that attracted me to
her because obviously
i'm quite strong in my faith i believe
that the man should take the lead and
obviously provide um provide for the
family spiritually emotionally and
physically right and when i met her she
said you know what i want men to lead
i'm more than happy to be a stay-at-home
wife i'm not career driven those things
just ticked my box and i said let's do
this
would you would you say your wife was
like submissive in like in that sense
the way you used to do the way you
described it
so what she did was she
empowered me to be to to walk in my
biblical masculinity to be the leader
she wants me to be so for example she
would say to me she'll ask me a question
from the bible i was reading this could
you explain that to me that for me i
felt honored by doing that as well and
yes because she was single for a while
there are a few issues that we clash but
we're both fallen human beings but this
is where you've got to give her grace
but she's given me grace and she's
enabled me to lead
the way i should do you see i feel more
masculine being married than i was when
i was single
wait so okay question yeah sure if if
you had if you had a girl that wasn't a
virgin would you wait with her
if she's like i'm i'm
i'm born again
okay okay okay okay
because this is i think i think this is
one of the like big contentions that the
manosphere has yes with um with like
like with the church
because you have all these girls that
are like they've done their business all
of a sudden they've come to the lord i
have so much to say about that
so and so like on one hand i kind of see
both sides a little bit right because
girls it's like they're flooded with
attention from the time they're like yes
what 15 14 so like who makes the best
decisions at 15 14
especially like some girls like don't
have their parents around like right
some girls more than others right now
what is it so i see one i see one at
right wait wait but then on the other
hand these guys are like well why would
i wait when you gave it to the last 20
guys for free and i have to marry you so
it's like
i can totally see that yeah from a
manual sphere's point of view and there
is a slight skepticism because what
happens is and i think this is the
mistake that some of these so-called
born-again virgins do yeah they think
because you've been forgiven of your sin
doesn't mean you're released from the
consequences of your sin right and
that's the mistake you see so what times
what tends to happen and i think it's a
lack of humility whereby let's say
someone went through their whole face
right has come to see the light they
think that i'm a christian now i've been
redeemed right you should treat me as if
i'm some
sort of um virgin that's never been
touched i'm like it's like me going to
prison unless i did i committed the
hideous crime right i went to prison for
20 years came out and expect someone
just to ex you know a fellow
just because i'm a christian expect a
fellow girl to say oh i know you had
some sexual deviance in your past but
i'm just going to forgive you and just
let you go
there has to be some sort of humility
from my part right i think what these
born again virgins need to do is like
okay just because
i've taken a new leaf i've still got to
have some humility because there's going
to be a bit of skepticism right and
stuff like that now you know what i was
i was going to i was going to actually
building that one to two points first
point being this like
once like you've go through that let's
say the whole face and stuff like that
and i've known one person that's been
born again christian and stuff like that
right
and she's gone through
a lot of
dick
capital and stuff like that but
right yeah when she went through the
whole um being born again virgin born
again christian and stuff like that
right um she had a boyfriend at the time
right okay and to put it in the second
point being is like if you're cool if
you've done what you have to do right
and you've done bad like you've been
down in the dumps and you did anything
to survive and whatever that's
understandable but that's what we're
going to talk in your mic yeah we can
get like we can get past that but if
you're born again like whatever you go
get baptized and you're like oh i don't
have anything like that but you have a
boyfriend this is where this is where it
gets a bit like a bit more tricky
because
when you was doing all that stuff right
before that
you were just doing it for the fun of it
you was doing it to get by now that
you're born again and you're with a
boyfriend and now he's
been there done that i know you're
telling him
like oh i can't do this anymore because
i'm born again it's right now you're
looking like because the boyfriend is
going to have to look at you you're
going to be like are you serious because
like are you okay with your head like
we've just done this and now you're
telling me we can't do this anymore
until marriage right that just doesn't
make any sense i guess in that situation
what i would say is that that
relationship would need to end
absolutely
because like i say it goes to the
religious side you know there's a
scripture and new testament talks about
don't be unequally yoked with
unbelievers so if someone's claimed to
be born again and is still with a
non-believing boyfriend why are you
still with him yeah you're part of your
fruits are being born again so you're
going to cut relationships that are
toxic and that would be problematic yeah
but that's but that's when you're
looking at it from a perspective of like
he look so let's say for example they're
together and they love each other right
yeah and then he he knows that her pause
and he's okay with it she knows he's
past and he's okay with it and now she's
born again when stuff like that and
whatever
she knows about her and what she has
done
she can't do anymore yeah but but
obviously in the case of like if he
loves her and she still loves him it's a
bit harder to like oh
we need to end this relationship because
you want something that i can't do yeah
but then it's like why did you get into
relationship with me when you know
you're gonna but then it's the same
problem as there aren't enough men in
the church so i don't i think that's
really bad advice that the church gives
to be honest
what bad advice in terms of so like
they'll say they equally yolk so you'll
see you'll see girls turn down perfectly
good men like my dad's not really
religious but like he acts like a
religious person my dad doesn't drink he
doesn't like he doesn't have social
media he's a really hard worker like and
if my mom turned him down because like
he wasn't equally i think that'd be a
shame and i see it happen all the time
in the church where like perfectly good
men
they turned down because they're not
equally old so or part of the church
when there was like i think there was
like a dating event in my church and it
was like 85 women that signed up yeah
like that's that's crazy
there's a lack of men in churches but
this is where as the church we need to
cater it for men you know and stuff like
that and i agree but like we're here
yeah you know what i mean like that's
that's great for like the next 20 years
but the girls that are in church today
yeah that's not good advice yeah but the
problem is that there is there is an
ancient
wise man once said this to me if you
marry a child of the devil you have big
problems with your father-in-law so what
i'm just saying is that even if they do
bring and what what you bet what you
said between your parents yeah that's
more the exception than the rule but the
rule would be if they did marry someone
that was not a believer
long term that could bring some problem
because the problem is okay did we go to
church how do we discipline that kids
yeah i'm talking about the three r's
before you can start their relationship
because you know what it is yeah like
i've been so i went to states right
um for a whole year and obviously our
one of our coaches that i trained with
was
a religious man right and then i've been
to a church here now the thing is the
difference like there's a like
everyone's under apprehension that like
oh when you go to an american church
it's like oh you know all dancing and
singing and it is because i've been
there and i've done that like from
personal experience speaking i went to
there and i've seen people running down
the aisle catching the holy ghost